how much would we have to pay you for
the girls now go chat president boy yet
some illegal depart Department without
the part where teach without the trouble
[Applause]
[Music]
the assessment that we did in 2014
gave us 97 different countries that
victims came from that gives you a sense
of that scale there's no doubt that the
scale of modern slavery in the UK is
enormous
we're just seeing you might even say
just the tip of the iceberg
my daughter changes the fountain is 30
pounds
[Applause]
[Music]
look forward to water
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
in addition to Brett's of violence and
we also see indirect threats so if you
do then your family at home will be
targets we know where your children are
we know where your mother lives and if
you don't do what we tell you then
there'll be real trouble
[Music]
Weston forte pasta and Mopani okehazama
compliancy Subiaco cleansing subtract
Iraklion c panel meta pomona pena de la
famille chharia gadot words Bonnie
dilemma credible me no cause la valeur
LaFave and a fabu chorus on
[Music]
Shambu cases cop Despero shakhas
aspargus on amicus in each care mimic
tomato City Mo Fortis Perry Otto
[Music]
machi doing a MOBA taco Korea Kasich
reader sumatra Atticus musica Saba credo
cassava a